-Guys, it is Tuesday.
It's time for "WeTweet."
Here we go.
-♪ WeTweet ♪
♪ WeTweet ♪
-Welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we as a group
decide something
that we should post on Twitter.
I'm going to show you
five different tweets,
and we're all going to vote on
whether or not
you like each one.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats.
You see them there?
You can vote for all of them.
You can vote for none of them.
Whatever you want.
We'll see the results live.
Higgins, Roots, you all have
your clickers too?
-Ready.
-Alright, we're going to see
which one gets the most likes,
then we're going to tweet it out
so that everyone at
home can "wetweet" it.
-Ah. Nice.
-It's a shared experience.
Alright. Are you guys ready?
I think this first one's
got a lot of potential.
-You think this one's the one?
-I think this one might be
the first time the first one
might be the one.
-Nah, nah, I beg to differ.
I don't even have to hear it.
[ Laughter ]
-No, we switch it --
We don't go like that.
We don't go in order of
funniest.
-No. It's just you go.
-This one might be the one.
-Okay. Prove it. Bring it in.
Prove it.
-I don't have to prove it.
The audience has to vote for it.
-Wow.
-Yeah, wetweet. Here we go.
The first tweet is...
Ebenezer Scrooge is
the name of your child.
I mean, he's going to have a
little chip on his shoulder.
-He's gonna have an attitude.
Yeah.
-He's gonna have a little chip
on his shoulder.
Like, "This is my son.
Mr. Scrooge, what did you name
your kid?"
"Oh, Ebenezer Scrooge."
Okay, here we go.
The votes are in.
Let's see the results.
Alright. Wow.
[ Audience ohs ]
-Wow!
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Yeah. That's a little --
93-90.
-Yeah. I mean, very,
very honest audience.
-Yeah.
-[ Laughter ]
I'm gonna say they did not care
for it.
-They did not care for that one.
-Not one bit.
-That won't be the tweet,
I don't think.
-[ Laughter ]
-I hope not.
-I know it won't be.
-It might be.
-Well, it actually might be.
-[ Laughter ]
Yeah, that's true.
This next one here says...
I don't like that.
-Yeah, that's more --
-I don't want to do it 'cause
some people can do that
and the trick and the thing.
I'm like, "I can't even do" --
Even in Uno, I'm like,
"someone else shuffle, please."
-Automatic shufflers.
-You buy an automatic shuffler?
-Yeah. Like 18 grand.
-Mr. Fancy Pants.
[ Laughter ]
-20, 30 grand you spend on
a shuffler.
-Yeah. Exactly.
Alright, let's get the results
on this one.
[ Audience ohs ]
-Wow!
-Wow.
-I was one of those thumbs down.
-You were one of the no's?
-People can shuffle cards.
-Yeah.
-Alright, good.
Well, that first one might be
the winner.
-Yeah.
-[ Laughter ]
-This next one here...
[ Laughter ]
That's not fair.
-They're a lovely group.
-That's not fair but it's true.
-I mean --
-Those songs are a little --
-I know up to three songs
from those guys.
-Yeah, but do you know four?
-I don't believe -- I can't sing
all the words to four.
-[ Laughing ]
-No one knows four.
-Alright. Let's see.
Let's see the results
on this one.
-Whoa!
-Oh, my gosh, come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow, taking the lead.
-Wow.
-[ Questlove laughing ]
-Wow!
-That better not be the one.
-[ Laughter ]
-Please.
-I'm sorry.
-That better not be the one.
Alright.
-No, that gotta be the one.
-Alright, here we go.
-Oh.
-[ Laughs ]
-This next one says...
"Finally."
-Come on.
-Yeah, here we go. Let's see.
I feel like the audience made
their decision quick
on this one.
-Yeah. That's never a good sign.
-As soon as I said it,
we cut to the audience
and everyone was
just sitting there.
-They were like this.
-[ Laughter ]
-They made their decision.
-Yeah, they said no.
Well, maybe they didn't.
Hey, you never know.
-I feel like if they said yes,
they'd be still laughing.
-Right.
-[ Laughter ]
-Right now they're just --
They're no's.
Let's see. Here we go.
Let's see the results here.
Oh, not bad, hey. Not bad.
-Not bad.
Are you still laughing at --
-Yeah.
-That's my first --
Yo, that's my first no.
-[ Laughter ]
-What?
-That Counting Crows joke
gotta win.
[ Laughter ]
-We were joking.
-This last one here says...
-[ Laughter ]
-Oh!
-There you go.
We got the winner here.
-That's gotta be the winner.
-I mean, that's gotta be.
Come on.
That one people are nodding
their heads.
-Come on.
-It's good for the holidays.
Make everyone laugh.
I feel good about this.
Drumroll on this one.
[ Drum roll ]
The audience is giving me
a drumroll as well.
[ Cheers ]
-Come on.
What is it?
-Let's see the results!
Oh, yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
It looks like
that is our winner.
I'm going to post this
during the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like,
give it a wetweet, and enjoy.